[Dave] So welcome to Homework 1.
Homework is going to be a little different from quizzes,
so unlike the quizzes where you get instant feedback for each question,
in the homework you'll submit your answers,
and you won't see feedback on them until you submit your answers,
and after the deadline for the homework, we'll be posting answers
and having discussion about the questions.
So for Question 1, we want to see that you understand
how web pages are constructed and what a web crawler will do.
The goal for Question 1 is for you to find all the target links
in the sample web page that we've provided.
So for each potential answer here,
check the box if that corresponds to a URL
that's a target link in the sample page.